Just because a director is willing to push
the boundaries of decency in the name of entertainment
doesn't mean they're guaranteed to get away
with it.
Sometimes, studios are forced to drop controversial
scenes entirely, either to get a better rating,
or because of public outcry.
Here's a look at some offensive movie scenes
you never got to see.
It's infamous orgy
Anyone who's seen Andy Muschietti's adaptation
of Stephen King classic It knows that it's
plenty disturbing as it is, but if True Detective
creator Cary Fukunaga had been left in charge,
things would have been a lot creepier.
According to The Telegraph, Fukunaga, who
dropped out of the project in 2015 due to
creative differences, put together a screenplay
that "horrified" the parents of prospective
child actors.
The studio responded by completely cutting
two of the most offensive scenes in the script.
Neither were as shocking, though, as a scene
from the book that was cut from both the 2017
film and 1990 TV mini-series because it featured
the children having an orgy as a rite of passage
into adulthood.
No joke.
King responded to questions about the scene
with a statement saying "times have changed
since I wrote that scene and there is now
more sensitivity to those issues."
Divergent's eyeball stabbing
The first book in Veronica Roth's Divergent
trilogy contains a scene in which an unsuspecting
Dauntless newcomer by the name of Edward is
gruesomely stabbed in the eye with a butter
knife while sleeping.
A version of this disturbing turn of events
was filmed for the first Divergent movie,
but wound up getting axed.
Director Neil Burger came to Lionsgate's defense
over the decision to remove this scene, claiming
it was "cut out because it was interrupting
the flow of the story."
Gangster Squad's cinema shooting
The original trailer for the 2013 crime thriller
Gangster Squad included clips from a scene
where moviegoers are gunned down with machine
guns.
Just a few weeks later, James Holmes opened
fire at a Colorado cinema during a midnight
screening of The Dark Knight Rises, resulting
in 12 fatalities.
The sequence was rewritten and refilmed.
Director Ruben Fleischer explained the reasons
at a press conference, saying "The Aurora
shooting was an unspeakable tragedy, and out
of respect for the families of the victims,
we felt it necessary to reshoot that sequence,
and I'm proud of the fact that we did."
Deadpool's vulgar bar scene
2016's surprise smash hit Deadpool proved
once and for all that there's a market for
R-rated superhero films.
Some of the most popular scenes in the film
involved Ryan Reynolds and co-star T.J. Miller
trading profane clips at the bar owned by
Miller's character, Weasel.
"what, like wear a mask?"
"Yes!
A very thick mask.
All the time.
I am sorry… you are… haunting."
But one scene they wrote together was so over
the top that according to ComicBook.com, director
Tim Miller decided they had to just cut the
whole thing entirely.
"In particular, there was a bar scene that
was too vulgar for even the R-rated Deadpool.
T.J. and Ryan got together and wrote a version
of the scene that we just said, 'Oh my God,
this is too far.'
I mean there were so many people offended…
It was just mean and so I said, 'No.
We don't have to do that.'"
Coulson's fate in The Avengers
Hard to believe, but the first cuts of Marvel's
2012 mega-blockbuster The Avengers actually
came back rated R. The problem?
According to Marvel head honcho Kevin Feige,
it was because the tragic loss of SHIELD Agent
Phil Coulson was too graphic.
Feige told Movies.com, "We went back and had
to make adjustments.
Whenever you impale somebody from their back
and the blade comes out their chest, there
are issues."
Murphy's massacre in Robocop
The 1987 sci-fi classic Robocop originally
came back with a dreaded X rating - which
in the current rating system is an NC-17,
so director Paul Verhoeven made some tactical
cuts to the film to tone down the extreme
violence.
Most importantly, he cut two seconds of footage
from a scene where Alex Murphy, the policeman
who becomes Robocop, is massacred by criminals.
An elaborate model of star Peter Weller, who
played Murphy, was created just for the scene,
but after they cut the shocking footage of
his head getting blown up, the dummy only
ended up on screen for less than a second.
Spilling guts in Scream
Legendary horror director Wes Craven had to
fight to get an R rating for the 1996 classic
Scream.
Craven told Bloody Disgusting that the ratings
board originally wanted drastic changes.
"Initially their reaction to [Scream] was
that it was virtually obscene and that almost
the entire third act had to be drastically
altered.
You know, the whole scene in the kitchen with
the boys stabbing each other to establish
the alibi, all of that."
They also wanted the beginning of the film
changed, so Craven met them halfway by toning
down the stabbing scene, and removing one
shot of a character's intestines spilling
out.
Yuck!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out this other cool stuff we know
you'll love too!